what do you disagree with roll on so so
we agree on a lot what we disagree on is
um the biggest thing that i think is
most problematic is marriage
that you can't endorse marriage
and i think that if we look at what is
the optimal environment to bring
children into this environment into this
world if my buddy sauce wanted to have
kids do you want kids yeah for sure
hopefully we could agree that the
optimal environment is to be in a
nuclear family where the man and the
woman are in the household together
socially enforced monogamy has been the
bedrock of western society
so we agree on that however the red pill
speaks very low of marriage you guys
have a very in my opinion a very skewed
view of marriage based on 66 percent of
marriages are filed by women uh so on
and so 70 but of half of marriages end
in divorce right now at least in western
union uh yeah but statistically speaking
you got a 50 50 chance of having a quote
unquote successful marriage whatever
that's defined as and then of course
it's actually it's seventy to eighty
percent of okay your book depends on
whose numbers you yeah i was trying i
was trying to be as conservative your
book was 60 to 70 yeah that's why i was
trying to be conservative so if the
optimal environment is for kids sauce
once kids is to be married in the same
household
with a husband and a wife with a husband
with a man and a woman what how are you
define a husband and a wife is fine uh
the the the painting of marriage is not
helpful in my opinion based on what we
know about marriage so marriage is uh 40
to 50 in a divorce what's left out uh is
is kind of his character of divorce you
do 90 of the work she puts in 10 percent
and then uh she could she could find the
voice at any time and then you have to
split all the proceeds there's a lot you
leave out there rollo um a whole lot for
starters divorce
highly correlated with income
the least the less you make the more
likely you are to get divorced this is a
fact i got sources
and it's commonly known that like one of
the top two issues in divorce is or
breakups is money
and dave ramsey would say that uh number
one reason people get divorced as many
fights money problems okay so so one we
know that the more people make the least
likely they are to get divorced that's
that's a
fact with the regards about 250k you
flatten out i think at about a 25 rate
so one that's that's omitted from the
fact and then the the response goes well
alimony okay if the average man median
income for the average man take away the
bottom
and the top outliers is about 60 000 a
year okay
average is about 40 000 when you've got
the outliers okay
people aren't paying alimony on those
types of salaries so the average person
is most optimistic to thrive and i can
give you all the statistics about how
being single you're highly to be
suicidal depression uh
all these unhealthy lazy all these
different things the optimal environment
for a man is to be in a marriage okay so
for kids
for his mental health and again and i
got the studies we could look at the
studies if you want to look at the
studies suicide rate depression unhealth
all kinds of different things diabetes
awful if you're a man in your 40s
so the red pill is framing marriage as
this caricature
that maybe on the contractual side there
are outliers where women when women take
advantage of men
but the average case is that if you
know how to make money if you understand
some of the game side of things i would
say there's some utility and i think
what you guys do a good job is you stir
people away from some type of women that
are in my opinion selection bias sauce
you got married before
rightfully yes yeah and uh what did you
do to protect yourself in that marriage
oh i had a prenup he had a pre-number
right dave ramsey recommends prenups for
anybody that's independently wealthy
before they go into the yeah
correct you got a free now and i
protected you yes correct i got buddies
that have covenantal marriages per your
book got a couple buddies they got
married they kept the state out of it
they protected themselves right and so
on and so forth so i think primarily
this this character of marriage man is
is is i think very toxic on top of what
you you you go on to
glorify how being a virgin is ideal in a
marriage
which is for the woman
for both people for the man too man we
could correlate body counts
we could correlate body counts to less
happiness in a sex life the higher more
partners you have the less likely you
are to be happy in a marriage sexually
that's what that's proven i think if you
don't know what you're missing
if ignorance is bliss
so and on top of it and this is the part
i'm probably most bummed about and and
you identify as a christian as a
follower of jesus somebody i'm bombed
rollo that you left out all the
statistics about how unlikely you are to
get divorced if you are a person of
faith who practices their faith now i
know you're going to say that's the no
true scotsman argument it's not
if you believe in earning wealth you're
going to do certain things to practice
earning wealth if you believe the lakers
of the best basketball team you're going
to wear a jersey and go to a game
occasionally if you profess to be a
catholic or a christian you do things
that show that in that you go to church
you pray you do certain things so when
we factor all of these different
variables together when we factor in hey
if you make more than an average person
hey if you have a great sex life
if you if you maybe have a prenup if you
have independent wealth if you're a
person of faith the divorce rate
plummets way way way off the ground
lower body count and that's the part
roller that i'm like man this is such a
caricature of marriage that i was really
bummed out that you as a christian
didn't put any of this in there with the
caveat and i appreciated you putting a
virgin thing in there because i thought
that was fair of you and that's the part
where i go man if the optimal
environment for our buddy sauce is to
one day get married to have kids okay
why would we not tell him that why would
we keep this information from him why
would we omit this
is that your goal
is that your goal to do that that's
first and foremost is like what do you
want as a man right now because right
now we're we're in the 21st century
we're 21 years into 20 and a half years
into the 21st century okay we're still
clinging to old order ideals we're still
clinging to a 20th century actually
probably like it's 18th century ideal
when it comes to monogamy we are not
looking at it from a post-sexual
revolution and i'm saying for better or
worse i'm not saying this okay i don't
deal in shoulds i deal in is
but you do though because you prescribe
very specific things in your book the
rational matter
i understand
to be as objective i know it's
impossible to be entirely objective
right you believe in objective truths
but you prescribe so i don't describe
anything i don't personally we could
come back to that let me explain
i'm not in the business of making men
better men i'm in the business of giving
men the tools that they need to make
better choices to become better men
themselves i'm not trying to be a cult
later i'm not trying to be any kind of
i'm not i told this to jedidiah
yesterday it's like i am
i bristle at the idea of being an
influencer because to me it's like who
are you influencing and what gives you
the authority to be that of in quote
unquote influencer as it is right now
but let me just understand what you just
said right there and then i'll let you
continue it's it's almost like cause and
effect you said i'm not here to help men
be better i'm here to give them the
education to be better well it's the
same today
you were prescribing certainly there's
there's a big difference okay i'll
explain i'll explain to you why okay i
do not have a step-by-step program that
says follow this template and you will
have a great [ __ ] life i have nothing
neither do i i'm not
i'm not saying i'm not saying that you
do i'm saying that that's my approach
when i wrote any book when i do any show
when i write any essay it's not about
here's what you should do here's what is
happening what are you going to do with
this information okay it's like fire
okay
you can use fire to
you know heat your home and cook your
food or you can use fire to burn your
neighbor's house down and you can go and
set your your neighbors on fire as well
we're not endorsing that by the way yeah
but what i'm saying is that like it's
it's it's not the actual red pill that
is the problem it is how is that being
used so when people like come at me and
they say the red pill is about this and
i'll say no that's black pill doomers
that's the mgtow side of this thing
that's the mra side of this thing the
the when we started this whole uh the
whole podcast here it's like well what's
your philosophy this is your philosophy
that's your philosophy there is no
philosophy of the red pill the red pill
is apraxiology that i didn't need to set
that up right right right right right
and people are going to come at me
because they think it's uh strictly
related to like economics and stuff like
that but
um praxeology is basically the study of
behavior
with the intent of showing that that
behavior is something that it has a
purpose or a latent a latent function to
it kind of thing so so people behave in
such a way as as this is how it works
kind of thing so
when i am talking about marriage and
you're not the first person to throw
this at me is that they say well rolo
how can you be
red pill because you're married or how
can you be married because you're red
pill right and so i'm always stuck in
the big in the middle of all of that
because i have a great by all estimates
i have a fantastic ideal marriage for
most guys would say it's an ideal
marriage for 26 years um i have a kid
right so when when especially from the
traditional conservative side of things
that come at me with say well how can
you be so down on marriage i'm not down
on marriage in fact i make that point in
in religion i said i'm not down on
marriage i'm down on how we do it now
okay okay as i said before monogamy pair
bonded monogamous however you want to
define it like remember it's judeo
christianity doesn't have a monopoly on
marriage okay marriage has been a thing
between men and women for a very very
long time
whether it's in muslim culture or it's
in jewish culture or it's in like even
asian culture you can go back to feudal
japan and find people getting married
okay so they had nothing to do with
abrahamic religions but they're still
pairing off like that so there's
something innate in us that says hey
we're better together than we are apart
okay where it is functionally
evolutionarily advantageous for human
males and human females to compromise
their mating strategies come together
and be parentally invested in that
quote-unquote family unit which of
course becomes the first tribe that you
have and we can talk about tribalism
later on so i'm not against marriage i'm
against the way we do it now in a
post-sexual revolution explain that
because
that's a sociological phenomenon like
that that's that's social culture that's
dysfunctional yeah right that's why i
mean i don't follow culture rollo i
build culture do you have a do you want
to leave do you have a legal contract
between you and your wife i do have a
legal contract then you then you that's
part of your that's part of the culture
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]